يعيد الاتراك احياء طقوس سنويه كل عام
ليخلقوا مشهدا يمثل ما كانت تبدو عليه
ساحات المعارك قبل عده قرون انها ليست
مصارعه عاديه انه اختبار للقوه يطلق عليه
الاتراك تسميه يلي جراش اي المصارعه
بالزيت يقوم المتسابقون بدهن اجسادهم بزيت
الزيتون ليحيوا تقليدا منذ مئات الاعوام
وتبدا عمليه المصارعه الزلقه بين
المتنافسين يجعل الزيت من مسك الخصم تحديا
ووسط دراما التشجيع والهتاف يمكن للفائزين
الاحتفال بالانتصار بعد معركه طويله بينما
البعض يتذوقون مراره الزيت مع
الهزيمه ويتم استدعاء المتسابقين بتسميه
الاسود ويرفع المعلنون دعواتهم لله ليم
بالقوه ويؤمن الاتراك بان ممارسه هذه
الرياضه تاتي اقتداء بالنبي محمد وقد
احتضنت هذه الحلبه اكثر من 600 بطوله
للمصارعه وتشير الاساطير الى ان محاربين
تصارع في هذه الحلبه حتى الموت لتقام منذ
ذلك الوقت المباريات
[موسيقى]
هنا وتحتضن مدينه ادرنا حدث المصارعه
السنوي ولا تزال العاصمه العثمانيه
السابقه متميزه بمسجد السليميه الذي يعود
تاريخ بنائه الى اكثر من 600
عام وتظهر التقاليد التركيه في اصول اللعب
فمثلا يتوجب على الفائز ان يعان خصمه بعد
الحاق الخساره به وللفوز يجب على اللاعبين
ان يثبتوا خصومهم او يرفعوه بالهواء وقد
لا يروق للاعبين نتيجه الحكم مثل هذا
اللاعب الذي يحتج بقوله ان الحكم اضاع
عاما كاملا من عمره بعد اخراجه من
البطوله ويقول نادر تاكي ان عمليه
المعانقه هي واجب على كل مصارع اذ تشير
الى ان خصمه هو صديقه وليس عدوه وهنا يظهر
تكري خلال بطوله المصارعه وبعد ان لحقت به
الهزيمه قام خصمه بمعانقته ومساعدته على
النهوض كداله على الاحترام وغادر الملعب
يدا
[موسيقى]
بيدز